NARRATOR: It's 20 below zero
in Alaska's White Mountains
where Marty
Meierotto's reclaiming
his piece of the remote
wilderness, a 150
mile long trap line
he's worked more
than three decades to build.
MARTY MEIEROTTO:
We're about as far
away from home as I can get.
There we go.
We got to keep pressing on.
NARRATOR: His plan to increase
his profits by running
the entire length of the
line for the first time
ever is keeping him on the move.
MARTY MEIEROTTO: Breaking
trail, punching new line,
building sets.
It's hard work.
But it's part of the job.
That's what I have to do.
NARRATOR: But after four
weeks of nonstop clearing
and setting, he's still
only halfway done.
And every second day, he doubles
back to check on his traps.
MARTY MEIEROTTO: Bingo!
That's nice when you make
a set and come and get it.
Man, he's a dark one.
Big, dark male.
Man, that's cool!
NARRATOR: So far this season,
he's hauled in 25 marten,
despite the recent sighting
of wolverine activity.
MARTY MEIEROTTO: Son of a--
Wolverine really
trashed the place.
He was in the trap, but
he wasn't in there long.
NARRATOR: Marty set a
heavy trap two weeks ago.
But this predator is
notoriously difficult to catch.
He demolished everything
and the trap is empty.
They are extremely hard to hold.
Such a bummer.
All he left me was
a couple of hairs.
NARRATOR: Wolverines
are scavengers,
and they're persistent.
With more than
100 miles to work,
Marty's spread thin, leaving
his line vulnerable to plunder.
MARTY MEIEROTTO:
Wolverine are my nemesis.
They're bad hombres.
They're notorious
for just robbing you.
Now we've got a game to play.
Sometimes I win.
Sometimes he wins.
We'll see what he did over here.
Hey marten!
We got lucky.
That's a big male.
I was worried.
I thought, oh, he's going
to be picking all my sets.
You know, eating
the fur I catch.
But he didn't touch this
one, so that's a good sign.
He's a gentleman wolverine
as far as wolverines go.
Even though he's a sweetheart
of a guy, we need to catch him.
I got lucky.
Yeah, good deal.
NARRATOR: With night falling
over Alaska's White Mountains,
Marty wraps his day on a high.
Time to see what I got here.
This might be one of
my best picks ever.
Let's see.
One, two, three.
This is a red letter day.
I don't-- this is rare
that I do this good
and have this good of a day.
Seven, eight, nine.
16 marten!
Wow!
What a day!
Makes me want to just
keep trapping, keep going.
NARRATOR: The mega haul
is a record breaker,
the most Marty's ever caught
in a single day on the line.
MARTY MEIEROTTO: Man, I can't
believe it, but it's like,
pouring rain out here.
Everything's going
to get coated in ice.
Hopefully it'll stop soon.
I'm going to want to get
these out of the rain.
Well it's time for dinner.